hot breath you know you may sit there as
you write with it and i do this
sometimes when i get
stuck as is i will try to put
like like oh my god
i think on the second album i did i did
a whole bit about
the clampets go to maui and it was about
me taking my relatives
on vacation which i did i took everybody
in my family to hawaii
so as i'm sis and i there were some
things that they actually
did that are part of the thing but i
also
put in there i write down everything you
can think about about
hawaii on one side of the thing so it
was like hula dances
grass skirts coconut bras right and on
the other side i would say what what did
my relatives do they steal stuff they
yell
stuff out they and and
that was able to like write a joke i
said one night we went to a luau
and you know my uncle got up to do the
hula dance
and we all realize halfway through the
dance he's not wearing any underwear
underneath his hula skirt well that was
just
taking column one and column b and just
crisscrossing and go
how can i so in the case of the white
trash trailer girl
you know think of different scenarios
put her in la put her in new york put
her in the department store
and then list the department store and
then list the the traits
and that's where it starts getting fun
and funny and you know that whole thing
i i i think ron thinks that or larry
larry's the one that thinks the klampest
go to maui is the one of the funniest
things i've ever written
um
but yeah when you get stuck that's a
great little writing thing
is you know i remember doing a routine
about
men cleaning up the house and how we
have to get
credit for every little thing we do when
we clean up the house
and but i was stuck and so i wrote
everything traits of men and then
what do you do when you clean the house
you vacuum you dust you wash dishes
and then other what do men do we you
know
and and and just start crisscrossing
them and looking and going can i connect
that to that can i connect that to that
and and that is a beautiful way to plow
material
right there uh wow
it works it worked 30 years ago it still
works